la campagne ambitieuse du chili a débuté
ce mercredi alors que le pays a reçu 4
millions de doses du vaccin chinois
sinovac une campagne massive avec pour
objectif que cent mille personnes soient
vaccinés chaque jour d'ici à la fin mars
ce qui représente les 5 millions de
citoyens les plus vulnérables du pays
avec environ 500 vaccination le premier
jour nous avons rencontré quelques
problèmes logistiques duo flux de
patients et nous les avons résolus
demain nous espérons travailler beaucoup
mieux le stade municipal de la floride a
fait partie des 1400 centres de
vaccination que compte le pays
un calendrier a été mise en place par
les autorités sanitaires
parmi les premiers à recevoir leur
injection les plus de quatre-vingt dix
ans puis les hauts responsables de la
santé les étudiants en pratique clinique
ou encore les personnels et résidents en
maison de retraite
le vaccin est accueilli à bras ouverts
par le ministre de la santé indiquait
parisse et par la population
aujourd'hui était un grand jour pour le
chili la vaccination de masse signifie
une journée joyeuse pleine d'émotion et
d'espoir pour tout le monde mais surtout
pour nos aînés ici ma mère a déjà été
vaccinées nous avons fait le processus
d'attentes
ils sont entrés dans le box et elle est
allée se faire vacciner tout seul
et de là ils ont pris ces informations
et ils nous ont donné cette carte afin
que nous puissions revenir pour la
deuxième dose la date qu'ils nous ont
donnée le 3 mars
donc nous devons revenir pour obtenir la
deuxième dose afin que le vaccin soit
complet grâce à un nouvel accord avec
sinovac
le chili prévoit d'ici mars de recevoir
13 millions de doses supplémentaires
pour vacciner 70 % de sa population
d'ici à l'été
en décembre déjà le personnel de santé
des unités de soins intensifs
recevez les premières doses du vaccin
mme faiza bio n tech
aujourd'hui les pays compte donc bientôt
210000 vacciner en parallèle à ces
accords passés avec pfizer bio n tech et
sinovac santiago compte également sur le
vaccin américain johnson and johnson et
sur le suédo britannique astrazeneca